[Music]
what's gonna happen with retail over the
next seven to ten years is gonna be so
massively disruptive that I wonder you
want to talk about caching you want to
talk about catching a a trend it's it's
the conversation of the next 20 years I
mean the Lord in Taylors this toys-r-us
these are the previews these are not
anomalies these are these are previews
I mean JCPenney and Sears have this
literal chance of being alive this is
not a zero and this is where they're
going wrong they think this is a story
of internet versus yours correct age no
it's not hey it's much deeper than that
you start getting into Lord and Taylor's
and Macy's and Bloomingdale's they've
got double pressure they've got the
Internet issue they got brands going
direct to consumer and more importantly
the brands the remembers their vendors
are clearly uncompetitive there's a
double-edged sword
I think Ralph Lauren's gonna be out of
business in 15 years like these brands
are not marketing and Instagram they
still think it's print and other
[ __ ] and I mean Uniqlo I mean it's
it's by the way of being in Singapore
right after Uniqlo meeting and seeing
Uniqlo everywhere that see that it's
almost two dimensional you have the
stores that are like this axis
yes what's their reasoning that's right
how do they reinvent themselves and you
have a brick and mortar versus internet
versus here I'll have you provide that
customer then you have the brands brands
actually can survive you know some of
them are doing really well hundred
percent
you know the questionnaires upside yeah
they've either very well if the yak they
learn how to market to this new consumer
right probably the problem is old brands
at heart yeah I mean the problem is it
you know whether you're old or new it's
just your behavior right I always tell
people like look there's 68 year old
executives who are a hell of a lot more
intuitive to what's going on than 26
year olds that I know like it's
unbelievable how how much this is a game
right now of haves and have-nots that's
it that's it Spotify I'm a big believer
Spotify I love you know you're too old
you need to find can I tell you why
Spotify though it's actually not because
kids listen to it or anything of that
nature there's not a lot of companies on
earth that have that many credit cards
getting recurring revenue each month
their ability to add OTT Spotify
tomorrow starts doing videos on music
Spotify tomorrow did behind the music
and did one-hour documentaries of every
emerging artist they would get an extra
$10 a month from everybody at my OTT
live some real ideas for them
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
I think there's an overestimation and
over focus on hustle work your face off
which which I'm very proud I've been
very passionate about but I don't think
there's as much focus on you know
empathy and gratitude and give more than
you take and and and perspective which
is stop focusing on dumb [ __ ] so I was a
little strategic on the sneakers
[Applause]
[Music]
Minnesota middle America you know I have
a funny idea
I want my book event in Minnesota during
Superbowl weekend
to be the biggest event attended because
that's just funny and ridiculous so we
will be doing that so be prepared for
Saturday February 3rd in Minnesota a
ridiculous book launch if you're in the
Minnesota area if you're flying into
Minnesota if you want to be a part of
amassing thousands of people into one
place so that everybody's like what
football legend is their noses Gary B's
book party I want to I want to upend and
disrupt Super Bowl so let's do that Gary
Vaynerchuk calm slash Super Bowl event
fill out the form if you want to be part
of the crew to help not because you just
want to help because you're gonna move
Minnesota and you can drive people to
the event or I've got some idea House
Alex how are you vaynernation Alex is
here
[Music]
it's over ambition and and substantial
humility and so I've been able to
articulate at least for me in a
comfortable manner of like clouds and
dirts like have big goals like go for it
be smart really be thoughtful but uh
always be humble and execute and stay in
the trenches always be a practitioner
and your craft those things matter to me
if what matters at the end of the day is
if you agree with me by narrowly that
it's happening here now the question
becomes what are you gonna do about it
first thing you need to do is everybody
in here need to take a step back and get
really self-aware really quickly because
self-awareness and empathy are the two
pillars that will make you successful
these are the two things I do that
nobody sees because of my persona
because of other alpha characteristics I
have they're the disguised superpowers
that have gotten me here today but the
reality is a long time ago through
amazing parenting and the serendipity of
being an immigrant at the right time I
got real self-aware real fast and
started triple downing on what I was
versus pandering to everybody else and
so the security and confidence and all
the other things that were put into me
allowed me to be good at this game for
the last ten years and the reason I'm
stressing such an EQ kind of fluffy
thing to you it is the framework that
will allow you to be successful it is
strategy either you have the right
strategy or even the wrong one too many
kids under 30 want to get there so fast
and it breaks them because they shortcut
and they create the vulnerabilities that
don't allow them to get there so it
would have just looked my 18 year old
self in the face and said your
intuitions are right do this do that
exactly right you'll be real happy you
got it thank you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay bye-bye all right bye-bye
hey no worries play oh yeah I'm well I
just moved here from Indiana on Thursday
Congrats thank you I hoping to get some
time from you
yeah whatever you got some free time sit
down be us with you okay well you do me
a favor you send me an email right now
okay in a title put on the guy from
Indiana okay tell me what's on your mind
okay and then I'll try to get your date
in January when I actually have openings
man that's awesome awesome and
appreciate your luck to you
take care brand wins every time and and
their kissing cousins like all the
skills that make somebody great at
something that we would all argue is on
the other side are tracks it's the same
[ __ ] so I love talking to kids in like
urban underprivileged demos I'm like do
the same way you sell weed is the same
way you can build a hundred million
dollar company it's the same [ __ ]
game the same way my friends sold
[ __ ] CDs from the back up it's the
same game it's just the framework right
and the same way whether it's courses or
offers or whatever it is it's and it's
patience and really you guys have the
advantage because you can wait a little
bit longer because you've got something
in place so there's a very intriguing
time to win - when make that jump higher
every discipline tomorrow have written
content every day audio content your
podcast will kill ya and and again
remember watch what I'm doing not what
I'm saying clearly it said you said a
lot it's taken from me why did I care
about my podcast and rebranded the audio
experience like why did that happen not
for my health it's because I believed in
the medium and since I rebranded and now
I'm a top hundred podcast without ever
doing a podcast don't hire for skill or
don't train for skill train for mindset
make sure when you start adding people
that you know iris why am i hot on iris
to give her a compliment I think she's
got skills but when I look at her and
watch her she has intuitive
communication skills which can be
deployed against anything when him the
taste you can be a chef of any meal if
you have the mindset to be open to not
say you're just a sous chef of sushi but
you can also be a classically
trained French chef as long as you're
open so please please please first input
this is the most important thing I can
tell you as you start evolving it's
about being open and nimble and excited
about change which is a very rare
commodity for an employee because they
were taught to garner a skill and trade
on it if you're talking about what I'm
up to which is [ __ ] all time it's in
those subtle [ __ ] margins and higher
for the five skilled team members I need
an order to chop up and do pillar
contents and all that kind of stuff
instead of again this is the value of
the nuance in the detail of talking to
people who've done it and played the
game and they go no go and hire for the
attitude for the kid who's hungry not
because you work for you three
throughout the year that's the skill is
a commodity the mindset is everything
Emilie appropriately realize that SIA
and got it is the same exact thing I'm
sure of that
am i doing Nate and trout after this
tonight okay can you put that in the
schedule holy [ __ ] I flew back from
Singapore with that dude he's an
architect I'm just some random guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is cool
[Music]
on a bigger macro patience and failure
they all ladder up to one thing which is
insecurity the reason people don't put
themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
which then dictates their behavior which
then gets into all of this Wise's if you
like don't hold on to it in with the
thought of in case it fails because you
just need to realize it's your Scarlet
Letter literally the reason people are
scared always is the outside force
having a failing business and everyone's
like Oh see you could never do or
whatever the cliche [ __ ] is right yeah
it just doesn't [ __ ] matter
you know why so that's one piece and
even if it didn't succeed what there's
such better people like what I'm such a
better person than other people because
I can build a business that's [ __ ]
that's it if you told me it's too big to
fail I'm like that makes sense but if
you also told me four years from now it
doesn't play I'm like okay lyft or
Google or Apple or some trouble like I
don't feel like it's too big to fail
first of all I don't think anybody's too
big to fail the only company that I
could say I feel 100% is here in ten
years is Amazon and Facebook if Mark and
Bezos are running it
[Music]
no no thanks for coming out Jesus what's
not gratitude is a hundred percent
gratitude the fact that I'm even a human
being I don't want to be a rhinoceros
seriously like what's going on here no I
mean it I take [ __ ] in a super macro
like I'd much rather be me than this
[ __ ] ugly green carpet kidding I just
wanted to make a joke I love Brie I love
green I made my shoes green like but you
know what you know like I what's the
alternative like being blessed with the
for hunt you know I love this 400
trillion to one I know some of you know
it like so you've been blessed with a
life I get it you didn't you weren't
born into a rich family you're the wrong
skin tone yeah they're sure that I get
it but [ __ ] just like got the we got to
get that you got the you won the lotto
you want it you've got to get that do
something with it
especially now your grandparents didn't
have this the internet is crazy [ __ ] it
just is it just is and so why do you
think everybody's getting out in now
because three old white guys don't
control the media anymore the [ __ ] do
you think is happening here this is the
greatest era ever for anybody the market
the platform is the Internet this is
unbelievable unprecedented times we will
look back at this 200 years from now
like these [ __ ] had a good
opportunity this is buying realist do
you know somebody bought the land that
we're on right now for $1 at one point
that's what's happening with us on the
Internet the attention of the end
consumer is cheap right now you can grab
it around whatever the [ __ ] you want to
be about and it doesn't cost you
anything other than your time and so
many of you are complaining but then are
too fancy to put in the 15 hours a day
to get it I got no respect for that I
got no respect for anybody who complains
and isn't putting in the work because
it's an excuse to not do
now let me call you on this issue and I
see some of you get it you could trick
99% of the losers but you're not
tricking the 1% so the only people
listening to your [ __ ] are the other
losers in your circle truth straight
[ __ ] facts to the face only person
listening to your [ __ ] are the
people you surround yourself that are
losers too don't complain nobody's
listening nobody that matters your mom
has to listen well let me give you an
update she thinks you're a loser too
I just want to try to buy the Jets way
more than buying the Jets like if I pull
this [ __ ] off shits gonna get crazy like
and it's crazy because I really feel
like I'm going to it's like I laugh at
how much I actually think forget enough
listen to amass the wealth to do it is
ironically funny to me that's the part
that I'm most confident about I'm most
confident that I'll have the money it's
does that time well when the Johnson
family wants to sell it what happens in
culture what happened like forget about
all forget about making the money the
fact that I have the audacity and the
optimism that not only will I amass the
wealth but that specific team like I
don't want to buy the bangles you know
like so it's so crazy how it plays out
in my head but here's the best part and
you'll be there to see it if I don't I'm
having so much fun and so much happiness
trying to get it and trying to pull all
of you up along the way while I'm trying
to get it [ __ ] if one of you get it I
would love that because then it would
happen on merit you were good enough the
thought that maybe the next owner was
built from something I created would be
so bad [ __ ] crazy you know and I've also
got a super secret plan and I'll share
it here today for the first time
I figured if I can get every single
person in America to really give a [ __ ]
about me getting the Jets that when they
become available if I'm not ready
financially I'm gonna crowdsource the
[ __ ] out of it okay
talk to my seventeen year old self
you're gonna be you're gonna be right
that's what I would say man I did
everything the way I want I'm so proud
of how I did this and I haven't even
started but like I ate [ __ ] like I just
don't you know you know you just don't
get it you will only get it if you know
somebody that knows me during that time
you'll only know me if you know somebody
I went to high school with and they'll
tell you that every weekend of my entire
[ __ ] high school life all of them
I work 13 hours a day that every [ __ ]
summer vacation day when everybody did
[ __ ] went to the Jersey Shore and hooked
up I [ __ ] worked you'll only know if
you actually saw my tax return only ten
years ago because I didn't make any
[ __ ] money because I was building a
legacy doing the right thing building
building skills being patient I only
give advice that I took I only eat my
own dog food and so I would tell him
you're gonna do it right thank you guys
[Applause]
I just want to see how good I can be I
don't know if the same am I've only
known this game you know I just want to
see how good I can do like I like
building businesses I like you know
deploying my thoughts just way I feel
like my intent is in a good place feel
good about myself
I feel good about it and it's curiosity
like I loved working that I love
producing impact I love producing
products
I love challenging myself to see how
well I do understand culture and
attention and the game and like it runs
the gamut and I want to build the
infrastructure for all the things that
matter for me in the next 40 years right
so it's just playing the game hey thank
you guys thank you thank you thank you
[Music]